from the moment she left a high-profile
job at the United Nations to enter Dutch
politics Finance Minister sikit K has
faced intimidation insults and death
threats after a man showed up at her
house with a burning torch and her
family started to fear for her life she
decided to quit politics it's become
very unsafe and it is something that
also according to university studies
scientific studies is underpinning an
attitude towards uh Progressive leaders
particularly women overall it is
physically unsafe uh and it actually
erodes ultimately the quality of our
democracy and the rule of law resigning
after 13 years in office prime minister
Mark R leaves behind the legacy of
economic Prosperity but also of historic
low trust in politicians R has been
tainted by several scandals his last
government collapsed after failing to
reach a deal to curb migration his
possible successor Dyan Yaz zilus a
former Refugee is campaigning on
stricter migration policies too many
people are coming to the Netherlands uh
so that amount we have to lower that
amount um and that's a a very big task
for the for politics policies the
anti-immigration party of here Builders
has long advocated the latest plls put
his Freedom Party in the lead closely
followed by a zilus conservative
liberals and the labor green Coalition
headed by former European commissioner
France timbermans internationally this
election will be closely won with a
possible victory for the far right and
new faces determining the Netherlands
political future step fast in Al jazer
the make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer